♪ ♪ ♪
- Regarder un paysage,
c'est pénétrer dans un pays,
c'est découvrir très rapidement
ses produits, son architecture
et ses gens.
- (narrateur): Pour bien des
Français, on est ce qu'on mange,
mais on pourrait aussi dire
qu'on est le lieu où on vit.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Plus mon espace est beau,
plus, logiquement, les gens
qui sont dedans se sentent
bien; et c'est le reflet
de ce qu'ils sont, quoi.
(bêlement)
- La France est une mosaïque
culturelle, historique et
géographique.
- Tous les 6 km, vous changez
de paysage, en France.
Plus un paysage est divers, plus
il peut s'adapter à des crises.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La France, en fait,
mais l'Europe et beaucoup
d'autres pays, leurs paysages
d'aujourd'hui sont l'héritage
d'activités humaines passées,
sur un territoire qui a
une histoire géologique
et une histoire climatique.
- Yves Michelin a fait carrière
en étudiant l'histoire paysagère
de France, dont celle de sa
région, le Massif central,
en plein coeur du pays.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici, on trouve une série
de volcans unique appelée
la chaîne des Puys.
♪ ♪ ♪
- On estime qu'on est les
dépositaires d'un des rares
endroits au monde où on peut
comprendre un des mécanismes
essentiels de la tectonique,
qui est la déchirure
d'un continent en deux.
Et on a ici une collection de
plus de 80 volcans. Pratiquement
toutes les formes imaginables
qu'on trouve dans le monde
entier, elles sont réunies ici.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Si tout ce paysage témoigne
d'une histoire géologique
riche et puissante, pour
Yves Michelin, il témoigne
aussi de l'évolution de
la place qu'occupe l'humain
dans cet espace.
♪ ♪ ♪
- 200, 300 ans avant
Jésus-Christ, ce paysage-là,
il est déjà agricole.
La végétation spontanée ici,
c'est la forêt. S'il y a pas
de forêt, c'est qu'il y a
de l'activité humaine.
Quand on voit de l'herbe ici,
derrière l'herbe, il y a
des vaches ou des moutons;
et derrière les vaches et les
moutons, il y a des éleveurs.
Si on enlève les éleveurs,
c'est les arbres qui remplacent.
Est-ce que la chaîne des Puys
complètement boisée, on le veut
ou on le veut pas? Est-ce que,
localement, on a envie de vivre
dans les sapins ou pas?
- La réponse à ces questions
s'est imposée d'elle-même à
bien des endroits en France.
Allons voir la Vallée
de la Bruche, en Alsace.
Si cette vallée est une région
aujourd'hui bien forestière,
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas.
- Derrière moi, on retrouve
une trace du passé industriel
textile, en fait. C'est une
usine textile, telle qu'il en
existait dans tous les villages
de la vallée de la Bruche.
En gros, il y avait 52 sites
industriels textiles sur les
25 communes du territoire.
- Les gens travaillaient à
l'usine et détenaient aussi
des terres qu'ils cultivaient.
C'était leur mode de vie.
On les appelait les
ouvriers-paysans.
- C'était une terre nourricière
puisque chacun travaillait dans
l'industrie textile mais se
nourrissait des fonds de vallée
pour de l'herbe pour les vaches,
les coteaux pour faire des
céréales, des champs de pommes
de terre et les secteurs
d'altitude pour nourrir
les animaux en pâture en été.
C'était une vraie économie
locale, qui a bien fonctionné
jusqu'en 1950, après-guerre.
Et tout ça a périclité. Et de
fait, les ouvriers, eh bien,
ils ont quitté le territoire et
ils ont abandonné leurs terres.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Même s'ils représentent
un faible pourcentage de
la population française,
les agriculteurs sont en
grande partie responsables
de l'ouverture des paysages.
S'ils abandonnent la terre,
c'est la friche qui prend le
dessus. Mais là où l'agriculture
est prospère, c'est un autre
phénomène qui se produit.
- C'est la tendance à
l'agrandissement des parcelles.
Les agriculteurs âgés n'ont pas
de successeurs parce que le
foncier est trop cher, et donc
libèrent de la terre, qui est
rachetée par des agriculteurs
qui en ont les moyens et qui
agrandissent les prairies,
agrandissent les champs.
Et donc, en agrandissant,
suppriment des haies,
suppriment des bois, et
donc, simplifient le paysage.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Face à un paysage qui laisse
de plus en plus place à des
lieux sans caractère, l'État
français réagit. Depuis plus
de 30 ans, le pays s'est doté
de certaines politiques
paysagères, mais surtout d'atlas
de paysages, qui ont permis de
bien caractériser le territoire
et ses paysages.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce travail, il a duré 10 ans,
pour couvrir l'intégralité du
territoire français, et il a
permis d'affirmer qu'on avait
une diversité de paysages
qui était absolument
extraordinaire.
Vous traversez la France du
nord au sud ou d'est à l'ouest,
tous les 6 km, vous changez de
configuration, de physionomie
paysagère. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de cette diversité,
de cette richesse? Et éviter,
notamment, qu'on banalise
ça parce qu'on sait très
bien que les agriculteurs
seront moins nombreux.
- Pour le chercheur Laurent
Lelli, si cette diversité
dans le paysage est l'un des
fondements qui caractérise la
culture française, elle offre
aussi plus de résilience, par
exemple face aux changements
climatiques.
- Plus un paysage est divers,
plus il peut s'adapter à des
crises. Et on le voit bien
actuellement, c'est dans les
territoires qui sont diversifiés
qu'on trouve le plus de sources
de revenus, à la fois pour de
l'alimentation, pour produire
des agricultures diversifiées.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La vallée de la Bruche a
voulu retrouver cette diversité
paysagère. La région a été l'une
des premières en France à agir
contre cette déprise agricole et
à mettre en place une politique
paysagère dans le but de rouvrir
les paysages, c'est-à-dire de
remettre certains territoires
en prairie.
- Hubert, tu veux continuer
d'ouvrir ou bien comment
tu vois ça?
- On a ainsi impliqué
divers acteurs locaux, mis
du financement sur la table
et engagé des agriculteurs à
prendre part au projet. Et on
a ciblé les endroits à ouvrir.
- Ici, on a mené l'opération
de réouvrir ce fond de vallée
là qui amène au village.
L'objectif est de redonner
des espaces ouverts.
- Un agriculteur comme
Mikael Rochel profite ainsi
de certaines portions de terrain
pour ses troupeaux. Il contribue
aussi à entretenir le paysage,
pour le bien-être de tous.
- Ça permet de créer déjà,
pour les gens qui habitent au
village, un milieu de vie qui
est agréable. C'est quand même
plus agréable de vivre dans
un endroit où le soleil passe
plus facilement, où c'est des
prairies verdoyantes, que de
vivre aux abords de la forêt
où ça reste humide et où
le soleil ne passe pas, quoi.
- Ça crée du lien social.
Certains affichent dans
les villages en disant :
«Depuis qu'on a réouvert
nos fonds de vallée entre
deux communes, eh bien,
on se parle parce qu'on se
voit, quoi», tout simplement.
- Aujourd'hui, le paysage de
la vallée de la Bruche est
un peu plus ouvert qu'avant,
avec plus de prairies. Le nombre
d'agriculteurs a doublé en
30 ans. C'est donc dire que
pour réussir un tel projet,
il faut y mettre le temps.
- Ce travail-là, il s'est fait
sur un pas de temps quasiment
de 25 ans, 30 ans, et il a été
possible parce qu'il y a un
engagement politique long.
- Regarde quand même le point
de vue qu'on a. Regarde!
- On n'a pas regardé la carte
postale de 1970, mais on a dit :
«On veut ça». Ce n'était plus
possible puisque c'était un
mode de vie bien particulier.
Par contre, ce paysage
d'aujourd'hui, il correspond à
une agriculture d'aujourd'hui,
à des attentes d'aujourd'hui
par rapport à la société.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le succès de ce travail a été
souligné partout à l'échelle
française, dont dans la chaîne
des Puys. Aujourd'hui,
à la base de certains volcans,
les pâturages réapparaissent.
- On a de la chance d'avoir
à notre disposition environ
500 hectares à faire pâturer.
Nous mettons en commun
2000 moutons sur la chaîne
des Puys.
On est quand même fiers
de pouvoir voir la cime de
nos montagnes. On ne peut pas
s'imaginer, si on n'était pas
là, bien... tout va se reboiser
et ça n'aurait aucun intérêt
après, pour personne.
- En 2018, la chaîne des Puys
a été inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO. Le site
des volcans est protégé,
mais sous une nouvelle forme :
une protection naturelle, mais
habitée, avec son agriculture.
- Cette espèce de chose
absolument impensable,
naturelle et habitée, c'est
ce que la Terre est devenue
avec 7 milliards d'habitants.
Il n'y a pas d'endroits au monde
où il n'y a pas quelqu'un qui
passe. Et ce quelqu'un qui passe
ou qui habite ou qui utilise,
il est partie prenante de cette
Terre.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le paysage de France attire
par sa beauté, mais ce paysage
peut devenir à risque
si on le prend pour acquis.
- Aujourd'hui, on n'a pas
les moyens d'entretenir
toutes les surfaces qui étaient
entretenues quand vous aviez
beaucoup plus d'agriculteurs,
il y a un siècle. Donc il faut
s'adapter à ça.
Si on veut un paysage de qualité
diversifié, il faut reconnaître
en tous les cas que les
agriculteurs sont des jardiniers
du paysage, et surtout,
que l'entretien soit rémunéré.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce que nous dit le paysage,
c'est quand on regarde un petit
carré d'herbe comme celui-là,
ce petit carré d'herbe là,
il est connecté au monde entier
par les politiques, par les
prix. Et donc, quand on va
changer une politique,
quand on va changer les prix,
quand on va changer un accord
commercial, on va changer
l'apparence de cette petite
parcelle. Et quand vous
multipliez toutes les parcelles,
bien, vous changez le paysage.
De comprendre ça nous permet
aussi de faire mieux la
politique.
De toute façon, le paysage est
un choix. Et quand on le choisit
pas, il en arrive un autre.
♪ ♪